I'm like I'm happy to present uh David
weitz and he'll be talking on Dynamic
matching rounding and specification
David White's is an incoming assistant
professor at the tech neon in Israel
until recently he was a visiting
computer scientist at Google
earlier he was a madwani postdoctoral
fellow at Stanford University and
earlier still he got his pH at Carnegie
Mellon University University's Theory
group
his research focuses on the design and
Analysis of algorithms particularly ones
dealing with uncertainty about the input
including online Dynamic streaming and
distribute algorithms
thanks Jason
clearly
um yeah so thanks for the introduction
uh thanks to the organizers for inviting
me
um
before I dive in I should say I have a
bit of a soft spot for uh Simon so it's
a
very pleasing whenever I get invited
here it's also I'm moving to Israel next
week so this is something of a closure
for me
um which is not to mean you know this is
like the end please invite me here again
um so as I said this this place has a a
bit of a soft spot for uh Simons I've
spent the non-negligible parts of my PhD
here uh the first program I spent here I
think of uh something of a an academic
birthplace for me
um most recently I was had an excuse to
hang around Simon's when my wife was
giving a talk at women in theory and I
spent uh spent the day thinking about a
problem at uh has just across the street
and uh that kind of gave the last
ingredient of a result in particularly
pleased about that you heard about
earlier today and I'll I'll tell you
about a bit more about later on
so this is just to say that you know
this institution this particular
building or uh and it's great to be back
and uh with this motivation personal
motivation I set out to make some slides
with a little bit of a help from uh from
the family
um and with that let me uh maybe start
actually telling you about something uh
something technical
okay so the topic of this talk will be
uh the dynamic matching problem which uh
soil already introduced earlier today
but if even if you haven't seen it we'll
we'll reintroduce it now and in a
particular I'll focus on uh key uh
techniques that have played an outsized
uh role like a substantial role in the
development of results in for this
problem
okay so the dynamic matching problem uh
the the interface is kind of the same as
pretty much everything we've heard in
this Workshop so you have an endnote
graph undergoing Edge updates so
additions and deletions and what you'd
like to do is maintain some graph
property in particular in this talk we'd
like to maintain a large matching so a
large node disjoint
set of edges High approximation ratio as
usual the approximation ratio is just
the multiplicative ratio between the
matching we're maintaining in purple and
the max matching which I'll denote by mu
of G
okay so this is a two-thirds
approximation
so we saw those of you who saw the first
talk of the day uh already you know this
problem has been studied uh
a little bit in the last decade or so
soil did a great work of kind of
summarizing uh the type type of time
approximation trade-offs we have and
there was a good discussion about
hardness for the uh exact problem so
I'll I'll not belabor this too much I'll
just maybe uh try and kind of cluster uh
three main regimes of time approximation
that people have shown results for
so first we know uh slightly worse than
one half approximation in pi log time
other than this we know some trade-offs
uh like better than a half in some poly
polyanti maybe a sublinear n
and most recently we've developed a
number of results for better than one
half in Pollock time if you uh relax the
problem and just allow for size
estimation as opposed to actually
maintaining uh the edge
until now
uh good so the goal of this talk is to
focus on some key tools in the space
specifically key tools in the Pollock
time polyog update time regimes
and specifically these tools are
sparcification based routing and
rounding based sparcification and I'll
make all this uh clear soon just to say
this there's been some some work on on
this
um
now bearing in mind that the kind of
overall uh overarching theme of the
program is not just Dynamic algorithms
but also applications of dynamic
algorithms in speeding up static
algorithms also kind of mention a few
new adaptive Dynamic data structures
which you might find useful for speeding
up
a fast Dynamic almost maximal matching
subroutines and optimal Dynamic subset
sampling algorithms and I'll I'll make
both of these things clearer towards the
end
good
um so without further Ado let me Focus
again we want to focus on sparcification
based rounding question number one or
question number zero is what exactly do
we want to round just to kind of make
sure we're all on the same page
and what we liked around is uh points
and the degree bounded uh fractional
matching politude okay so it's a vector
that assigns non-negative values to all
of the edges such that every vertex has
sum of values incident on it which is at
most one
okay if this is a binary Vector then
that's exactly the matching constraint
no vertex could be matched more than
once and here we're just relaxing the
integrality constraint
uh good uh what's a measure of quality
of these uh of such fractional matchings
it's just the approximation ratio it's
the number the the overall value
assigned to the edges so the the L1 Norm
of x divided by the max matching size
um so I won't spend too much time
talking about known Dynamic fractional
matching algorithms I'll just briefly
mention what these are and that's kind
of going to be the input to our rounding
subroutines
in the fully Dynamic setting we know a
number of algorithms that give slightly
worse than one half approximation in
poly log or even constant time
uh so maybe correct me if I'm missing uh
too many important ones but uh if I am
that that's what these uh this ellipse
is for
uh we know better than one half
approximation and sublinear and time
where the uh update time depends on how
much better than one half you get
and in the decremental setting we know a
number of one minus Epsilon
approximations and poly log time
originally just for uh uh bipartite
graphs but now also for General graphs
okay so we're gonna we're gonna kind of
take these as uh given and we're going
to try and see if we can get some good
integral matchings from from these uh
so okay so what's what's the interface
for us uh what we're going to have is a
dynamically changing fractional matching
X
and we get updates from the user it says
look this Edge e I'd like to change its
value to be sorry this Edge e I'd like
to change its value to be V and I
promise you that this the obtained
Vector X will remain a fractional
matching
okay and naturally what we'd like to do
is maintain an integral matching that
has value comparable to this fractional
magic in particular we're going to ask
for one minus Epsilon approximation
okay so those of you have thought about
uh
matching photo by mentioned before note
that this is only really doable for
bipartite graphs where the largest
integral matching is value exactly the
same as the largest fractional matching
uh so in general graphs this is not
quite doable so just think about a
triangle graph and assign values of a
half to all the edges the max matching
here is of course one
and there's only
three nodes here
um which is less strictly less than the
uh it's like two-thirds the this
fractional matching uh but I'll I'll
talk uh talk about what we can do for
General graphs uh later in the talk
go to the setup
so without further Ado let me start with
uh the first approach basically okay so
roadmap for the talk I'm going to give
you uh you know a little bit of an
Insight of maybe four papers in this
space uh say a page or two uh a slide or
two a piece just to kind of give you a
sense of some ideas that uh that were
useful in this space for you to
hopefully be able to use them in your
own work
okay uh so the first item in the space
was uh this rounding wire sparsification
and Joint work with Moab Shiri who I
thought was somewhere around here but
I'm wrong uh salil and cliff
uh where we noticed that we can
basically use partial rounding of this
fractional uh matching X to get a
matching sparsifier so a sparse subgraph
that preserves large matchings
you know a little bit more specific
precise about what I mean by sparse and
how good of an approximation uh
preservation of matchings I'd like
and then all we need to do is
periodically solve in this sparsifier
in this lazy lazy recomputation approach
so basically once I've you know if I
maintain a sparsifier in the background
then I can just compute a one minus
Epsilon approximation in the sparsifier
in linear time or linear over Epsilon
every Epson mu steps
okay so what this is going to give me
well the update time is obvious though
at least the amortized update time is
obvious it's just uh the work divided by
uh the period uh period length so size
of the sparsifier over Max matching
times F squared
and the approximation is essentially as
good as the size of the max matching the
sparsifier over the max matching in the
postgraph
right just because over Epsilon new
steps nothing really nothing really
changed
very quiet someone asked a question
okay
um good so given this uh General
framework there's really two kind of
quantities of Interest we'd like to
bound
uh for the update time we'd like to
Upper bound the sparsity of the graph of
the score supplier
all right so that's uh this point over
here and for the approximation we'd like
to lower bound the quality of the how
well how well this sparsifier actually
preserves
okay so yes
at every step in time you you basically
know what U of G is because you're
solving a fractional problem
good so the question was how do I know
mu of G
um to actually be able to kind of
estimate the length of these periods
presumably uh yeah so given given this
fractional matching I already have some
constant approximation so it doesn't
have to be Epsilon mu but you know
something in that ballpark
other questions
good and the good so Sebastian's
question is how do you compute this
sparsifier and that's pretty much going
to be the focus of most of what's what's
coming right so how much time do you
need to spend for this part
Loosely without defining what properties
you want to preserve uh so I guess I
mentioned this in passing uh sparsifier
I'd like this sucker to be sparse and
I'd like to preserve magics
other questions
we're on a roll with questions here so
this will become more and more
interactive this way
okay so
um
our first Approach at the Computing such
as parsifier following up on Sebastian's
question is in hindsight probably the
most natural thing could uh we could
think of
whenever I change the value on a
particular Edge I'll just sample or
resample that edge based on this value
okay so this new value I guess the new
value is V so I'll now decide whether or
not I add or keep this Edge e and the
sparsifier with probability V Times log
of rep squared
externalizing the dependencies on
Epsilon it'll be a bit clearer why later
but for now this is just a kind of point
out that uh this dependence on n and
Epsilon is
for those of you who kind of want to
think of where this is going this is
exactly where you think is you think
this is doing there's going to be some
turn off balance coming
okay uh so for our analysis uh maybe uh
three applications of turn off will tell
us that this uh this is a good
sparsifier
uh so first of all uh with high
probability the size of the sparse of
fire is going to be the X Norm I'm sorry
the L1 L1 Norm of x times log over x
squared
the L1 Norm of X is not much uh not much
larger than mu maybe like three halves
times larger so this is basically uh mu
Times log of rep squared so what we get
is log n
over x to the fourth
okay
um as for the approximation
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a more or less unbiased estimator
of x
so for every Edge e if it's in the
sparsifier we'll give it a fractional
value of Epsilon squared over log n
okay so it's supposed to wash out with
this probability over here so the
expected y value of every Edge is
basically its x value maybe times one
minus Epsilon for a bit of Slack
okay what is this bias well two things
first of all the L1 Norm of Y is
essentially the same as the L1 Norm of x
again just a simple childbound and uh in
addition the vector Y is a fractional
matching in s
uh why the expected Norm for every
vertex is less than one it's like one
minus Epsilon and so just by turnips and
all since all of these values are small
you're still
with high probability you're not going
to violate the degree constraint for any
vertex
okay so what we get from this is that
the max matching in the sparsifier is at
least the value of this fractional
matching in y so remember in this talk
we're only talking about bipartite
graphs so the the max integral matching
in s as value at least the max
fractional matching in NS which we just
said is basically the same as as our
initial fractional matching which we
wanted to round
uh
so just to kind of summarize what we get
here is uh log n times x to the minus
four time to periodically compute the
matching for Sebastian's question about
how much time we spend on maintaining
the sparsifier nothing right we spend
constant time whenever I change the
value on the edge I just reset
and the approximation ratio is one minus
Epsilon times whatever the approximation
ratio of the fractional matching was
because
you know that other instructions
other Notions okay so just to repeat the
question maybe make sure I I understood
are other Notions of sparsify as useful
so then other sparsifies than this
particular sparsifier or yeah just
because I mean people have studied
specifies for different things and it'll
be nice to have
you know one kind of construction that
works for many settings so is it
plausible that there is a
spot that's not
customized to matching but also works
for matching
um
that's a great question off the top of
my head
okay
anybody else wants to chime in with a uh
I like the comment like this the the
random sampling is also done in like cut
specifications for example sure is it is
it similar like is ordinality similar or
I mean I just told you the analysis
there's not a lot going on here it's
just a couple turn-offs on top of each
other
sorry
ask this question again ask this
question again in two slides okay
thanks
I'm not gonna repeat the question
because uh
awesome
uh so I'm going to try and keep things
at this like abstract level of I only
care about rounding the fractional
matching
um without talking about the integral
problem the kind of integral results we
get from this which is to give you a
flavor of the types of corollaries you'd
get from this so for example rounding
the solar 17
um worst case update time uh algorithm
of uh Cheyenne Monica and danupon you
get a half minus Epsilon approximate
Dynamic matching algorithm with poly log
worst case update time
the same same result was obtained
concurrently by Moses and uh I think
both of whom are in the room with China
um but just to kind of say his is a kind
of simple way given given a fractional
algorithm you get the fairly simple uh
simple algorithm
uh okay now addressing uh Sebastian's
question about adaptivity uh the one
downside of this algorithm as well as
that of uh Moses and uh that I just
mentioned is that this algorithm is only
works for an oblivious adversary
some of the animations are broken here
but so imagine imagine you can see this
okay so what's the problem the Adaptive
adversary can repeatedly delete the
sampled edges right this is a very
sparse graph
so if you simply say about the if you
think about a star then you know the
sample will really only give you a small
number of edges here and uh well the
adversary can just decide well in that
case I'm going to delete those edges so
at least this approach seems seems
pretty uh
um okay and I guess I don't have to
belabor this point too much within you
know for this audience but maybe for
people watching this uh talk on YouTube
later on uh I should kind of
re-emphasize that we care about this
notion of adaptivity
in order to be able to use our Dynamic
algorithms to speed up static algorithms
or within other algorithmic subroutines
right this is the whole uh concept of
this uh of this program
okay so uh take two at the problem of
rounding okay we saw a very simple
algorithm that will give you uh lossless
around in bipartite graphs because in a
blimis adversary let's try and do
randomize the in an Adaptive setting
yes
slightly confused like is the issue that
the fractional algorithm like isn't
adapted or is it really just
like the fractional algorithm is
deterministic so that's as adapt as
adaptively robust as it gets yeah
the problem is just you know I'm I'm
only focusing on a subset of the edges
and if the adversary knows that then you
could just say look you tell me what the
answer is oh it's this Edge okay delete
that
what's your answer now I'll just keep
deleting until you run out of edges
I'm getting
contract like why why was it correct in
the previous slide
this is the same algorithm from earlier
yeah yeah
so
so suppose think of like the simplest
fractional matching for this solution so
let's say just one over n on across all
the edges your sampling log n many edges
yeah
that is an Adaptive adversary you're
just going to destroy this I'm just
going to destroy this and log in steps
the fractional matching doesn't need to
change it's still still pretty good uh
matching fractional matching
but at least for this algorithmic
approach I'm host
if you follow the example that's great
it's if not it's not not too crucial
just thinking of face value that this
did not work against that develop
research foreign
so idea number one to make things work
against adaptive adversaries is instead
of actually maintaining a sparsifier
just periodically Computing one okay I
don't really care about the sparse of
fire during these periods when I'm you
know between my matching computations so
let's just do that okay so we're gonna
do periodic sparsification and compress
steps one and two of the uh high level
approach we saw earlier
so what we're going to do is
periodically partially round X to get a
sparsif is and then solve an s
that's the only high level uh difference
so we round and compute this matching
every Epsilon new steps we're going to
take the time that takes the round plus
the matching computation
and the update time
will change appropriately okay so now we
also have to factor in this round
uh rounding step
okay so the analysis is more or less the
same as before we need to bound the time
to round plus the size of the sparsifier
over the matching size the approximation
again is the quality of the matching
sparsifier
and as far as adaptivity all we really
need is that our data structures that
allow us to periodically
run steps one and two together work
against an Adaptive adversary
okay so for example the fractional
matching is deterministic that's great
we can use that and then whatever other
data structures we need to be able to
quickly uh round our partially around
our fractional matching and solve
it okay so Computing and matching in
this time in order to deterministically
by Juan and Petty so I have to tell you
about rounding and what data structures
I run in the background
yes no
then you'll ask a question
uh so what is the difference good
so the difference is that previously
good so let me go a couple slides back
maintain this sparsifier all the time in
the background
and then Computing and matching okay I'm
saying screw that maintain whatever the
instructions you need but only compute
the sparsifier just before you compute a
matching end okay
I suppose
all right
okay so how do we compute them as
parsifier
okay so here comes uh the second idea
which is uh sampling via Edge coloring
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at some graphs that are induced
by edges with essentially the same x
value
the same say like Power of One Plus
Epsilon
and then in order to sample edges in
bulk in a correlated manner
we're going to start by Edge coloring
these graphs
okay so a quick reminder an edge
coloring of a graph is an assignment of
colors to each of the edges so that no
vertex has two edges of the same color
because it's in other words it's a
decomposition of the graph into
matchings every color is a matching
uh you clearly need at least Delta
colors right every every Max degree node
needs at least one one color per Edge
and that's more or less the right the
right answer Delta Delta plus one is the
number of calls you need
by the degree constraint since all the
values in the sub graph are basically
assigned to these edges are one plus
Epsilon to the minus I no node has more
than one plus Epsilon to the I many
edges
so I can call it this graph with roughly
one plus Epsilon to the eye colors I'm
going to allow myself a little bit of
slack maybe color it with c times as
many colors C can be like three or
something and that will allow me to
maintain this adaptively I will tell you
how it's it's a very easy exercise but
believe me
okay so I've I've colored this graph
into you know small number of matchings
now what I'm going to do is sample a
small number of these
colors small number of these magics
okay and what we got from this is you
know this over that things wash out the
Seas wash out uh one over this is the X
x value
so what we get is that this new
sparsifier contains each edge with
exactly the probability we're using for
the independent sampling earlier on
okay so again
number of colors divided by uh sorry
number of colors sampled with our
repetition divided by number of colors
is log n over squared times roughly one
plus Epsilon to the minus sign
following the calculation is great if
not that's not really the point
the the important thing to take away
from this is that this allows us two
things
first of all
um with slightly more sophisticated turn
off bounds but not a lot more
sophisticated we can argue that we get
the the same approximation as with
independent sampling the the key
difference in the analysis is that now
uh edges are not sampled independently
but you can show that they're negatively
Associated and you still get the same
type of correlation
uh this if you're interested in learning
this one nice uh probabilistic tool
sometime uh the near future I recommend
this primer I think
I'm working on expanding this also so if
you want to hear about some more cool
stuff ask me about it
okay so the approximation is just as
good as independent sampling now what
about the update time of this uh of this
uh rounding scheme
the size of the sparsifier well it's
actually fairly easy to analyze if you
don't care about the exact logarithmic
dependence
the sparsifier is made up of say at most
log squared and many colors log square
that many matchings all right does log
in many ranges of I
and each one of these I'm sampling login
colors
so log Square then many colors a color
is a matching
so and by definitions it's most the size
of the max matching so the size of the
sparsifiers at most mu Times log Square
then
so what I get here is that the update
time is size of the sparsifier which I
just told you is Mu Times log squared so
it's basically log Square then
if you're a bit more careful you could
shape one of these logs on
this example yes for all one over
Epsilon I've done this for all uh log n
over Epsilon menu ranges yeah
I see so now
instead of independent sampling
sampling matchings instead of
Independence exactly so correlated
sampling as opposed to the independent
sampling
and the only reason you're doing this is
because you can do the first part
adaptively
the only reason well I guess there's two
reasons I'm doing this
good uh so I can do this part of that
sorry I'll repeat the question is the
only reason I'm doing this because I can
do this adaptively so the first step
adaptively
um okay
I think good I think one one key aspect
here is the fact that I'm in some sense
I actually maybe I should have written
down the time surrounding which I think
is the maybe the more important aspect
here so the time for rounding here is
well I'm I'm sampling login colors login
ranges this is like poly log you know
you can worry about what log exactly but
you know some poly log
and then I'm just writing down the
sparsifier
okay so rounding is very cheap
for the independent sampling if I were
to
independently round every Epsilon new
steps I'd have to go edge by Edge
because Lively I'd have to go edge by
Edge and flip a coin for that edge which
would take me m time instead of
something proportional to Max matching
which is at most
yes
sure so Mike my interpretation is like
by coloring the edit you're kind of like
hedging your bets over all the possible
edges there that your adversary can can
delete so instead of like having just
one set of like a sparsifier where the
the address so you can just delete all
the edges yelling a bunch of specifiers
so the adversary cannot like kind of
Kill You by just like focusing on one
single specific you're kind of a
passionate events over all the edges
is that
um that's an interesting interpretation
I I don't know that's quite what's going
on because at the end of the day at
least the way the analysis uh comes out
I'm pretty much saying this is the same
as sampling independently the the key
difference is that I'm able to resample
Fresh every Epsilon new steps and time
proportional to me
so I had a question here yes
right I'm saving the time to round is Mu
as opposed to n well
[Music]
every poly login
Instagram magic so you so his argument
doesn't mean any more
you're saying it doesn't it doesn't
surprise
I see yeah if you're saying like this
this login so if you think about the
star example if you just say look I'm
going to take a larger poly log the
adversary can still shave off like some
small Pi log number of edges and still
leave you with an empty sparsifier
unless you're able to recompute uh
the other question
um so I'm still a bit confused about why
independent sampling doesn't work
um so all of the edges have the same XP
value up to one plus Epsilon Factor
right sure so you have a set of M edges
and you want to sample each one
independently with probability x e so of
course yeah this this can be a
simplified a lot I know where you're
going with this yes this can be
simplified now yeah
yeah so you don't have to go through the
edges one by one
just yeah for sure yeah just sample of
what binomial
so if I mean this is uh you know with
the benefit of hindsight this this is a
simpler way of doing this for sure
a value
temperature value so so I've got like a
certain number of these edges okay I
want to sample each one of these with
probability it was essentially the same
probability
I can just draw a binomial to figure out
how many of these I have
I then run like a smooth uh Shuffle or
something and just decide which one of
these edges I took
it'll be it takes time proportional to
the output yeah
okay so so far we've seen an oblivious
algorithm we've seen an Adaptive
algorithm what's the next step
all right thanks uh right so the
downside of the algorithm we've seen so
far is where the hell do you find random
bits all right there's been programs
here and elsewhere uh thinking about
these types of questions
so let me uh briefly mention one
deterministic approach and then uh move
on to yet another
so this one is uh based on ideas of
papers of a paper of uh Cheyenne and
Peter and subsequent uh the amortization
by Peter
which again looks at the same induced
subgraphs of edges with the same the
same values
what we're going to do in each of these
is essentially run Piper drowning so
what do I mean by this okay so Daniel is
nothing vigorously that's great so we
just walk around the graph we get a
bunch of paths and cycles and in each
one of these we take say either the red
or the blue edges whichever are more
plentiful
um we double the value on whatever we
actually kept rinse and repeat
okay this will roughly preserve the
total value as well as the value for
each node at least uh within the context
of these GIS
and for technical reasons you stop at
some Epsilon value instead of going all
the way to integrality basically because
if I do this for every every one of
these possible values I could round a
bunch of edges to one and get some
issues
a little bit faster um
okay so if you know I get a bunch of
these grants I'm kind of an in parallel
trying to partially round these
and I'm claiming that I preserve the the
degree of the nodes but because of a
rounding up issue right so if you think
for example about this node
let's say the value here was uh half you
know I round this up now it has a value
of one
if I also round this uh in another in
another one of these sub graphs and now
all of a sudden I'm going to have a
bunch of a bunch of edges into them
okay
if all that that's great if not this
this is more or less the right level of
abstraction
are you assuming
I'm gonna assume it's a bipart I'm
pretty much the entirety of the talk I'm
going to assume the graph is bipartite
and then I'll have maybe one slide
talking about
um
so basically do you want to do this
you want as far as
part sparse graph right fantastic okay
so right now I just gave you uh more of
a like a static approach for this and
now let me tell you how I'm going to
make this dynamic basically what we're
going to do so this this subroutine is
it's not too hard to see basically runs
in linear time right so every every step
I'm having the number of edges so
basically just cost me the number of
edges I've originally sub graphs
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
apply this sparsification for the
subgraph GI whenever the number of edges
in it changes by one plus minus Epsilon
Factor
so it's going to cost me you know the
number of edges in G over uh Epsilon
times the number of edges in G so this
step of a specification time cost me one
over Epsilon
amortized cost of this
and since uh since I only actually I
don't need to do anything until the
value changes by more than one plus
minus Epsilon I'm basically one my steps
on approx
y okay
um
so without going into too many details
the size of the sparsifier is uh
basically the max matching times
polylogs
and
um what we get from this is a one minus
Epsilon approximation and size of
sparsifier over Max matching so still
poly log update
foreign
is good to remember because we're going
to reuse it shortly
let me just summarize what was the state
of the art until uh maybe a year ago
so the first algorithm we saw was this
oblivious rounding approach which had
the adds on to the fourth dependence on
Epsilon log logarithmic dependence on M
I then showed that to get the same
results adaptively with high probability
and an expectation with constant
probability you can even drop the
dependence on n
the deterministic uh approaches that
followed later give you uh some
polyepson poly log dependencies which
are
quite a bit higher but probably could
could be improved but I'll point out
that there's kind of a fundamental
barrier at improving these uh approaches
that we were stuck at until uh fairly
recently
which is this Epsilon to the fourth
seems pretty hard to overcome for for
two reasons
okay so uh there's two factors the first
is the periodic recomputation which says
take size of sparsify over Epson uh size
of sparsifier over Epsilon that's the
time to compute a large matching every
Epsilon new steps your sparsify has to
at least contain a matching so in this
case scenario specify has size mu that's
that's already an Epson minus two Factor
and actually all the sparsifies we know
how to compute had the quadratic
dependence on Epsilon
so yeah you really have to take the
product
um it was a good time to plug in a
recent paper with uh Peter and uh Aaron
which allowed us to sidestep basically
uh break this barrier quite uh
quite significantly and in particular uh
effectively meet what seems like a
barrier almost unconditional barrier
barring some
some philosophical discussions we had uh
yesterday
um
the best recourse bound you could hope
for is one of Repsol so for every change
the fractional matching you would need
to change one over Epsilon edges
so this one of reps on seems to be
essentially the best you could you could
hope for
and uh let me also point out uh I have
like three rows here so let me tell you
exactly what we get here so
deterministically we get what we knew
how to get adaptively with high
probability
for the Adaptive high probability regime
we get sub polynomial dependence on n a
particular poly log log dependence and
we can even get a constant probability
output adaptive algorithm with constant
update
where I'll point out output adaptive
here means that the adversary knows the
changes to the output but does not know
your internal state
which I'll point out is good enough for
all the applications where we care about
adaptivity
right all the algorithms up until this
line uh were kind of cryptographically
secure so even if the adversary knows
what's what's what's going on under the
hoods you're still you're still doing
well
um
so let's see so we're yes
um what uh the Epsilon to the minus four
does one of the epsilons come from the
from the Juan Petty matching computation
so the the periodical computation is
Juan petty over Epson news that's like
two of the epsilons come from that
basically I have a linear time matching
algorithm you have a linear time okay
fantastic so one of the epsons you could
replace with say a sub polynomial term
using uh sushant and companies uh near
linear time Max matching algorithm for
sure
this next column becomes kind of
incomparable
okay
um
so how are you for time okay so I'll
probably
let me let me skip maybe one of uh one
of these slides I'll just kind of say
that there's a nice idea here about uh
rounding bit by bit from least
significant to most significant bits
sorry uh Jason how much time do we have
yeah okay so let's uh let's maybe skip
this uh the slide
um those of you watching the recording
afterwards you can scroll down here and
kind of read things a little bit better
uh I'll just point out that uh the kind
of uh
Black Box uh result we get here is a one
mice Epsilon approximate Dynamic
bipartite fractional matching rounding
algorithm with L squared over Epsilon
update time where L is basically the the
bit precision of the X values okay so
it's uh log of Min non-zero value uh one
over X
so if you remember from the call from
the table earlier I promised you a
better uh better dependence on N L could
be as high as log n
so we got better results here uh we have
some nice uh
pre-processing idea of partial rounding
to decrease the range of values so just
to give you a flavor of this to get an
oblivious result you could use the
simple rounding approach I mentioned
earlier we'll get you all your values to
be Epsilon squared over log n
and so L will now become log of of this
thing which is basically poly which is a
log log n and so you get the log log N
squared update time
um but more interesting uh approaches we
get for partial rounding in our work uh
rely on some some other new ingredients
uh kind of effective ways of getting
multiple sparsifiers whole sale so you
spend more or less the same amount of
time you spend to compute one sparsifier
at least in an amortized sense and you
could get a bunch of sparsifiers and
then allow yourself to kind of switch
from one to the other
and another interesting subroutine which
I'll briefly mention is we give a new
output adaptive Dynamic subset sampling
data structure which I I simple as it is
I think might actually find some
applications
um
okay so let me let me maybe spend a
couple minutes on some some tools that
were developed by this line of work and
for this line of work which I think you
might be able to do that
so up until now the entirety of the talk
focused on bipartite graphs but I
promised Chandra I'll tell them about
General graph so let me spend one slide
on this generally we cannot round
fractional matchings in general graphs
and nonetheless the known Dynamic better
than half approximate sorry worse than
half approximate fractional matching
algorithms are known to be roundable
so particular and this first rounding
paper we showed that you can use them to
get an integral matching algorithm with
the exact same approximation ratio even
in general graphs exact same up to one
minus Epsilon
and moreover in uh so the this year what
we showed is that you can use these to
get adaptive poly log time almost
maximum matching algorithms
um and the most recent paper we sped
this up and also showed how to get this
deterministically which
almost completely be randomize this
paper if not for the use for uh of
sublinear time algorithms
um so the notion I'll skip the exact
definition it's more or less what you
think it's maximal uh so long as you
squinted the graph and ignore a small
number of loads
and these approximately almost maximal
matchings uh seem to be useful pretty
much in the same way that maximal
matchings are if you're okay with a
small error so I think uh you know
whatever algorithms you have where
you're interested in Dynamic maximal
matching algorithms consider using
Dynamic almost maximum matching
algorithms they might give you exactly
the same results
um okay I'll also mentioned that we have
this uh
adaptive Dynamic subset sampling
algorithm the interface is more or less
what you think uh the you update the
probabilities for every element and you
want to support queries which outputs uh
set from a product distribution so every
element is fixed independently with
probability PPI
I studied quite a bit before and we give
the first to our knowledge output
adaptive algorithm for this problem
all right let me let me wrap up real
quick sorry I'm a couple minutes over uh
so just to summarize this uh Dynamic
matching rounding problem has been
studied uh quite a bit before and
underlies uh pretty much all of the
polylog time algorithms that we we know
in this space for bipartite graph for
magnetic graphs this means that it's
enough for you to focus on the
fractional problem if you want to get a
strong result for a dynamic bipart type
matching problem it's okay for you to
focus on Dynamic bipartite's fractional
matching
uh for General graphs the history hints
that all the relevant Dynamic fractional
matching algorithms are roundable so
possibly the same the same could
uh the most appealing question for
dynamic matching broadly is uh getting
the same type of results that we got for
size estimation for the actual problem
so actually maintain a better than one
half approximate matching and poly log
update time
as far as techniques and tools I guess I
spent the talk telling you about
rounding wire specification by rounding
uh this seems very powerful for uh for
matchings
can you use it for other problems
uh the Adaptive subroutines I mentioned
I think have further applications so I
uh I beseech you to find the
applications
and uh actually even Dynamic matching at
this point we have a number of pretty uh
pretty strong adaptive Dynamic matching
algorithm just approximate uh matching
uh we don't even have any compelling
applications for this yet so this is one
of these cases where the the tools
predate the applications
um I urge everyone here in the room to
think of such applications
and uh with that let me thank you for
your time
[Applause]
thanks Dave for the great and
interactive talk
um
uh maybe one or two questions if anyone
say
awesome
so could you use this program here
of course now you have something
deterministic and stronger words
uh so the question okay so question is
could we use this proactive resampling
technique I guess what what would be the
Hope here I mean as you say we already
have deterministic algorithms that seem
to be
uh that's a good question maybe Aaron
has a better idea I don't know
maybe we can take the yeah
what is the result rounding what do you
mean by the uh
um what is the statement what do you
mean so in the static setting what is it
that you're saying and
good so the result for generic the
result for General graphs is that
the particular fractional matching
algorithms that we know how to maintain
in Dynamic settings this I guess
actually is not the only one we know but
let's let's focus on this one
um this has particular structure that
allows you to show that actually it
contains an integral matching of
essentially the same value
so this is a half minus Epsilon
approximate fractional matching you can
show that it's no better but it also its
Support also contains a half minus
Epsilon approximate integral matching ah
so in that sense it's roundable
you don't lose you don't have to lose
the Integrity Gap basically yeah
could you show the slides on subset
sampler I just should understand what
does it do
you're all welcome to it
oh well maybe it was going to ask you to
change things but uh
um reads quickly yeah but I I wasn't
quite clear where the improvements came
from that got you to like one over
Epsilon I mean so like the yeah I mean I
guess I I
do ah good good so I'll okay I'll try
not to read through the slide but I'll
just mention uh one one point here
um
basically we we skip exactly the use of
one Petty and periodic recomputation we
just show how to maintain you know we
round direct integrality as opposed to
all the previous approaches that were
blocked at you know getting a sparsifier
size new repsilon new rep actually
nothing was as good as new reps on so mu
of squares and periodical Computing are
matching here we just round all the way
to integrity and we're good to go and
for General graphs
um we managed to improve the size of
sparsifiers from uh say mu rep Square to
me over apps so that's we also get
improvements for General graphs I feel
like the the result for bipartite is
probably more compelling where we really
just
none of this like periodic recomputation
just give me a matching and I want you
to always have a matching
all right for the Dynamics at sampler a
lot yeah
you got the slide so maybe I'm missing
something here
can't you do the trick that I think soil
was saying like why can't you just like
count the number of things that
different probabilities
and then
like um yeah that also works and that uh
we did not write for this version but
that's uh but what we have written up is
uh
a little more involved even than what uh
Sid further if you remember we also
talked about this at some point by just
sampling for a binomial for each ranges
effectively is good if you're if you
don't want the exact probability whereas
what we had uh here if you actually care
about exact probability I think that's
maybe the difference right
that that caveat right I see good good
good uh one one other aspect if if you
want to do this per per uh range per
like a few rounding probabilities even
if you don't care about the the
um
uh uh if if you don't if you don't want
a sample it's probably exactly Pi you're
okay with pi over uh one plus minus apps
um you have to bear in mind that this
one is no longer a one now it's like the
number the number of uh ranges of
probabilities that you care about this
would be like a log over apps
oh okay so I think that's that's
probably what's uh nicest about this uh
this approach as opposed to just
sampling from binomials and
it's not shuffling on top of that and
these are one skills these are uh
expectation and uh well expectation of
course
interest of time let's take many
questions offline thanks again
[Applause]